lady bird is written and directed by
Greta Gerwig and stars
Saoirse Ronan as a young girl named
Christine who would prefer everyone in
her life to call her Lady Bird
she's trying to navigate the remaining
years of her high school life while also
searching for a college she'd like to go
to she'd love to get out of Sacramento
if she was given the opportunity and
this is a coming-of-age story that's
different than most usually ones that
focus on a girl or about a romance of
some kind like she meets a boy and it
changes her life and then she's able to
go out on her journey and experience
great things
Lady Bird does meet boys along the way
here one of them played by Lucas hedges
but this movie is not a romantic love
story about Lady Bird and some boy this
is a love story about mother and
daughter and how the two of them are so
drastically different and how they both
make each other's lives really hard and
in just that one way this movie is so
fresh and so unique and extremely
pleasurable to watch this is one of my
favorite movies of the year it's
extremely well acted Saoirse Ronan gives
probably the best performance I've seen
from her she is so so drastically real
in this movie and one of the best parts
of what Greta Gerwig has done with her
script is that scenes kind of begin they
don't feel like they have a natural
beginning like most movie scenes do when
you sit down to write a script sometimes
you think about how am I gonna start my
scene well we'll have this logical
progression that builds into the moment
oftentimes scenes begin in Lady Bird
with characters mid-conversation
and you're like what were they just
talking about well it doesn't matter
because we're now observing this moment
and the moments are so well realized
because the scenes just come about that
technique keeps this film feeling so raw
the film also has a really great balance
of portraying our lead character at this
religious school that she's going to and
it's making it hard on her she wants to
blossom she wants to do a lot with her
life but there's a lot of restrictions
there normally when films have a
character at a Catholic school or
something very strict like that they
portray it as this big negative like a
really horrible time in their life where
they weren't able to follow their dreams
this movie
sidesteps that and presents it as simply
not necessarily a roadblock but just
something that Lady Bird has to deal
with it doesn't say you shouldn't go to
Catholic school it doesn't say like
don't believe in these things because
it's hard on you
it just shows moments it feels like
you're watching contained moments
throughout this character's life which
the best coming-of-age stories do that
all the performers across the board are
terrific Laurie Metcalf Lucas hedges all
of them really strong work there is not
a weak link in regards to the actors
here the film also balances the right
amount of embarrassment with realism
there's so many scenes here where you
just cringe for the lead character but
it's not awkward in the way that some
films do when it comes off kind of
pretentious like hey look at this really
awkward character we wrote aren't they
so unique and different and weird aren't
I a great writer Greta Gerwig really
does a great job to avoid all of those
cliches I'd be curious to know how much
of the film is improvised because the
dialogue flows so naturally between
actors I found myself really caring
about these characters I was wrapped up
in their lives and I was honestly
concerned about them I felt like I
wanted to befriend them and be like it's
okay you know there's gonna be a next
day you can get through this and that's
the sign of a great movie when you
forget that you're watching one and you
just feel so invested in the characters
Greta Gerwig has done a great job with
her solo directing debut she had
co-directed another film once before but
this is all her and she shines this is
an amazing debut and I can't wait to see
what else she does a few times a year a
movie like Lady Bird comes along the
kind of film where it feels like hey
this could go on a lot longer like I
would like to see what else these
characters do I want to know what else
these people are going to do what are
they gonna do tomorrow I want to know
what's happening in their lives and it's
almost sad when it ends because you're
thinking man I was really wrapped into
that it's short it's like 93 minutes but
it's quite an enjoyable watch and in
retrospect I have not one single flaw or
anything about this film that I felt
out of place it's a mesmerizing debut
Greta Gerwig should be really pleased
I'm gonna give ladybird and a plus it's
starting to expand to more theater so
that's why I got to see it today I hope
you guys do check it out it's worth your
time thank you so much as always for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here and get stubborn eyes
[Music]